hey everyone its micromotor closed I'm
excited to bring you this presentation
on the order flows Delta footprints and
it's one of the features on the order
flows trader software for mt8 and it
really takes order flow analysis to a
whole nother level
you know most traders who are into order
flow are familiar with the volume
footprint chart which is based on the
volume traded on the bid versus the
volume traded on the offer in the
two-way auction but there are actually a
few derivations of that data that is
extremely useful and extremely revealing
of what the market is doing at certain
times and like I said this feature is
available on the order flows trader 2.0
which we released a few months ago for
NT 8 and what really separates the order
flow straighter software from other
software out there is the education that
comes with it you know I do these
regular presentations and I actually
have a weekly live group training
session where all the users are invited
to come in and you don't ask their
questions and you know and just have a
discussion about order flow so I think
that's worth actually much more than the
software itself honestly you know I mean
that's it's one thing to have expensive
software you know to analyze the market
but honestly if you don't know what to
look at in the market it doesn't matter
if you have a million dollar software
program if you don't know how to use it
then you know what's it worth to you
it's worth noting and you know the
reason I decided to make this video is
because I want to show you that when you
have the right trading software and you
learn what to look for in the order flow
that you can actually see what's
happening in the markets and make solid
trading decisions and what I'll be
talking about today is a setup that I
call the Delta tail and it utilizes the
Delta footprints which you can see on
the order flows trader software but
before I begin a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contains substantial
risk is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk grapples
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results alright so what
is a delta footprint well you know I
said you know most people are already
familiar with the volume footprint chart
you know which is again the volume
training on the bid versus the volume
traded on the offer in the two-way
auction and the delta footprint is
similar and what it is it's the
footprint left by the delta internally
in the bar and it's very revealing to
the trader at certain points and
especially at inflection point so you
know where market reversals can occur
now there are specific patterns that
indicate market direction again I'm
going to talk about one of those today
it's it's what I call it the Delta tail
now if you're familiar with a normal
volume footprint chart this is what it
looks like this is the e-mini
five-minute bar chart and you can see
the volume traded on the bid versus the
volume traded on the offer you know at
each price level okay you can see the
imbalances and whatnot
now the Delta footprint what that is is
it takes the Delta you know the
difference between the volume traded on
the bid versus the volume traded on the
offer and you can go into the settings
go under a ladder content
this is the order flows trader software
now I don't support the ninja trader
order flows plus software this is my
software that's available for you you go
to sell tax you change it from bid-ask
to Delta now there's total there's four
different choices there and what that's
going to do is it's going to change a
normal footprint chart into a delta
footprint you can compare it and one of
the choices is if it's just Delta it
compares it horizontally you could
actually do Delta diagonally but in this
example I'm going to show you compare it
horizontally and so on the on the right
hand side you see Delta footprint so
just take a look at the first bar 27 on
the top right hand side so how do you
come up with 27 well on the normal
volume footprint chart at that price
level 27 last traded on the bid 54
traded on the offer so you're left with
27 108 versus 80 on a normal volume
footprint chart so you had net on the
net was sold in there so you had 108 so
you're left with net 28 at that
114 - 55 net - 59 67-63 - for now I know
what you're thinking you say well why
aren't you comparing it diagonally well
you can and I said and in this example
I'm showing it to you horizontally so
you can change it from Delta where it
just said on the setting from Delta you
can change it to diagonal Delta and
diagonal is another choice and it's
gonna if you do it diagonally obviously
it's going to compare 108 versus 54 as
opposed to 27 versus 54 on the footprint
chart so it's you know that's another
presentation for another day that's
something that I'll probably do
specifically for my users to take
advantage of the information and it's
quite revealing when you start looking
at the imbalances but what I'm going to
talk about today is what I call the
Delta tails and what it is is what it
looks like for a by and what it looks
like for a cell it's basically on the by
it's green candle all volume traded on
the offer side or the net Delta is on
the offer side except for that little
bottom part that's traded on that what I
call the tail and for a cell it's a red
candle with all the Delta on the sell
side that's why it's all negative there
with the little tail on top the positive
Delta on the top offer side okay so
let's take a look at the charts so you
can better understand it here so okay so
this is let's take it through a few
charts different types of charts really
you know quick and just show you some
examples I'm gonna go back you know what
day is this what am I oddish 15 is
August 14 August so it supposed to be
August 13 so let's just look for these
examples of the tails so basically what
I'm looking for remember is for a by I'm
looking for the little tail on the green
candle on the bottom or the tail on the
top of a red candle and let's just take
a look here and you know in this case I
think you got to be very strict on it I
mean you could say well like about a bar
where it's just
all on one side well yeah you can but I
mean to me those are the more obvious so
here's a nice here's a tail a by tail
you got the minus six here then it's all
positive Delta's here and you know
getting you know what's the mark going
it's going from 36 went all the way up
to the 40 you know up to 40 what kind of
heat are you taking from 36 you know
maybe down to what is that thirty four
and a quarter
thirty four and a half before it hit up
to thirty six and started going higher
but you know so that's you know to me
that's a decent trade you mean you had a
couple em stacked imbalance in there as
well which is encouraging then on the
way down after you get your swing high
up here your higher they actually got a
negative Delta up there you got a
divergence here you got a selling tail
and selling Delta tail and look at I'll
just sold off quite nicely down okay you
know I'm just gonna show you every day
here from I think that's one of the
thirteenth until it's it's Sunday night
right now it's actually trade date
August 20th it's about 12:30 at night
right now I'm recording this video again
I'm just getting my stuff ready for the
week and you know I really wanted to get
this video out there because I felt that
this was you know good information core
you know for a lot of people here's a
nice Delta Tail cell right here again
it's nice little move down again but
this is going right into the cache close
as well then it turns around starts
rallying up here this one yeah it's not
really a tail I mean you've got to price
levels there but again I'm trying to be
strict here in this example for this
trade setup anything
yeah you got a couple of one two here
one two there but again I'm just trying
to show it to you with one again you
know you got a six here you got a three
here you know does that qualify
I'm I'm trying to be strict here and say
no here's one you got the five Lots here
then it's all negative Delta
here's a nice buy oh this is the one I
had on the example actually - 103 on the
bottom then all positive Delta
here's another nice buy here at the 97
then all positive Delta
okay well here's one here's a cell again
it's August 20th that you know just
after 12:30 we'll see what his mark is
gonna go overnight if it's gonna sell
off her or what but you know it's
setting up right now you know you got
the 88 and you got the all negative
Delta fine nothing's going to happen
until Europe comes in but you know we'll
see so let's take a look at take a look
at a five-minute chart
just scroll back here beginning and
let's just see again same same setup I'm
gonna look for okay well this is a
buying tale this one didn't work
oh that again it's at 9:40 at night
there's a sell it didn't work honestly
those are the first two that I saw that
didn't work here's and this one didn't
qualify because you got the one but then
you got 14 down in there
this one again it's a tale I expect it
to be on top not in the middle this one
didn't quite make it you know you got
the 377 but get that - 48 there again
I'm trying to be very strict on it
here you go got one eight ten in the
morning and this was on the 13th I
believe you got a nice little move up
before the cash open and then I wants
cash opened you got the 73 then it's all
negative Delta and this one the market
just dropped beautifully after that I
mean you can look at it for 28 18 down
to 20 808 over the next 30 minutes you
know most people I know basically you
know they trade recipes but they trade
it during the cash hours anyway so you
know those few that didn't work out were
you know kind of slow periods but again
you know I watch don't you see how it
how it looks in all timeframes
you know I'm not trying to just pick
certain time frames you know this one
again if this is just for price levels
so I'm not sure I'd say yeah look at
this you know it worked out it's only
for price levels I'd like a longer bar
and that's right on the futures close
anyway
nope that doesn't qualify this doesn't
qualify either again this is not
qualifying again I like it to happen on
longer bars rather than bars of three or
four price levels here you got one
here's and I sell it so nice by worked
its way up
this bar says it's all buying again you
know in then it's followed by the bar
with the tail right here and then just
continues working its way up over the
next hour so again you know from the
what is that 28:46 area all the way up
to the 2850 area then you got a cell
right up here at your height of the day
you know I love getting signals you know
that highs in the day I'm not trying to
predict a high today I don't know
there's gonna be a high today until it
prints but then when it hits that I'm at
the high and obviously I got a
divergence and a ratio in the next bar
but more importantly you know I got that
tail right there you know that's a
terrific low-risk trading opportunity
right there because it's you know it's
trying it markets find an inflection
point and it starts selling off hit
almost funny my wife says I sound like I
slur my words sometimes but I'll see
when I record a lot of these videos you
know I sort of do these on the fly and I
do them late at night or early in the
morning so that's why sometimes it
sounds like honestly I think I sound
like I'm a drunk sometimes but I yeah
I'm really not I don't drink this one
didn't work out I mean this one again is
right on the futures close here other
than the reopen you know this was a cell
that just sort of went sideways on you
again you know it's a cell let's go back
here look at the time it was a cell that
went sideways on you but at what time is
6 6 p.m. at night ok so go forward here
really quick
anything anything Mueller no that's just
all cells I mean you can you can also
take all cells or all byes but yeah I'm
looking for the one with the tails this
one you got that one
volume in here so it's you got the tail
but then you got that out 153 in there
so it doesn't qualify you know this one
yeah I would you know I would qualify
that this one does the work out no
here's a cell here just sort of works
its way sideways doesn't really sell off
maybe you could have scalped the point
out of it this cell doesn't work out but
you'd probably already be short from
here anyway waiting for it to work out
but it comes right back even if you got
short here comes right back with this
beautiful by man imagine you're getting
long in here 2843 and look at that up
you know
ten points although if you remember
Friday we didn't get that big rally and
the ESPYs right at one o'clock then you
got a cell here you know at two o'clock
you got the tail 3:56 and the nice
sell-off and again now in the evening
session on the five-minute chart up here
at twenty eight fifty four and a half
you got the the cell well you'd be
selling to somewhere around fifty three
and a half actually
was it a typical low her yeah I sort of
went lower down into the fifty ones but
just sort of hanging around going
sideways sideways sideways and you got
the other cell coming in here right
right before midnight and just sort of
takes us to where we are at fifty and
three-quarters go back to that eight
range chart real quick so you can see
you know it's it's okay let me ask you
this right I mean I don't how many
training screens you have I know I've
got four screens I got 28 inch monitors
now and you know is it worth having you
know so you could buy you can buy an
extra screen you can actually buy you
can actually go to like some pawn shops
I've been to some of these pawn shops
and they're selling computer monitors
there for like $20 you know cuz before
when I was adding monitors that's where
I would buy my monitors from I just go
down to the the pawn shop and I could
buy a 23 inch monitor for like 20 bucks
and you know like sometimes if you're
buying two you could say hey you know
give me a better deal but you know is it
worth you know ask yourself is it worth
just throwing an extra
or up and throw in a chart like this up
on your screen for finding these these
types of trades you know when they occur
yeah I think it is I think it's worth it
honestly and again you know it's this is
a piece of information that's available
to everybody how many people are looking
at imagine how many traders out there
okay how many they all look at bar
charts alright this information is not
going to be available on a normal bar
chart and then you start breaking it
down well how many people look at order
flow majority overwhelming majority
ninety five ninety eight percent of the
people out there look at the normal
chart here I'll show you what they look
at is this your Delta so this is your
choices bid-ask Delta volume diagonal
Delta majority people they look at the
bid-ask Delta that's your normal volume
footprint chart alright that's that is
you know that's this chart here it with
your normal and there's nothing wrong
with it I look at that too and you know
but I also keep the other screens open
you know for specifically to find
instances where I see these setups now
there are other certain patterns I like
to look for in the Delta on the Delta of
footprint charts but you know I just
really want you to see what you know
what else is out there and again you
know imagine you just I just showed you
an eight range chart I showed you a five
minute chart and so it's not like well
it only works on certain markets in
certain time frames no it let's take a
look at some other charts here real
quick then I'll just go back here I
don't know what am I looking at here is
it let's take a look at crude oil
cruises in the middle of the roll right
now well you should be in you should be
an October crude now but anyway that's
just you know just scroll back and see
if it's if that same pattern is going to
be appearing in here okay well this one
again it's borderline I mean you do have
the tail here minus 18 you don't have a
you got a empty volume level in here
okay you know it's it's fine this one
didn't work out
but again you this is the one you'd
rather take you got taken in context you
know what do you think is going to be
more effective after this nice little
sell-off I had this one here 12 then all
selling yeah I would take that this one
yeah I would also take that this one you
should already be long up here not
looking to get long up here because you
had you know the buying opportunity
lower
okay well that was all that was in crude
I was on the eighth range going back a
couple days take a look at your old
currency then real quick yeah also a
range yeah I got three days in data
coming up on this so here right here
look at this low of the day you got your
tail -9 all buying what happens market
rallies
here's a bot here this is not a bi
rather I was gonna say it's a cell or
it's not a cell this is what you want to
see what you want to see it on a green
candle not a red candle and that's
important okay
because what's happening here is the
marketer is rallying then it's sold off
that's why you got the volume that's
traded there it makes a big difference
if it's on a green candle or a red
candle you can I'm not looking to buy a
red candle I'm never looking to buy a
red candle people always say why why do
you only buy green candles is because I
want to buy when the markets moving in
my direction okay I don't we buy in when
the markets selling off I want price to
start moving in the direction I'm
trading okay cuz you know I there's a
lot of times that you know you think you
can try and pick a little but you're not
you know you be buying it at 28 and next
thing you know it's trading 26 and you
try buying 26 is next thing you know
it's trading 24s you know that's not uh
that's a recipe for disaster again and
that that's what it comes down to people
kind of wanting to try and buy the low
or pickle oh I don't like to do that I
like to like to let the market you know
take me into the market you know so if
I'm looking to buy
I want price to be going up and if I'm
looking to sell one price to be going
down not in the opposite
you
almost had to buy here but not quite
almost had one here but not quite you
got that minus nine here just as you got
the minus nineteen up there almost tail
means that you got the tail but then you
just got that other volume in there
again I'm trying to be strict here for
this video because I think you can be
strict on this you don't f does thing
you know because once you start
handicapped and say well oh you know it
got the tail here you got the - - then
you got the - 24 in here I can take it
okay yeah it might work it might work
quite often but you know he's starting
to deviate from your trading plan this
was Friday afternoon after two o'clock
about 2:15 so as a sell it didn't work
out just once sideways on you then you
went you can go too close for the
weekend again I probably want to take
this trade because it's Friday afternoon
at you know 2:00 in the afternoon in
Chicago time cash markets are closed
already around the world and everyone's
getting ready for the weekend so that's
it yeah so okay so that's crude oil
that's your currencies that's a minis
you know that's I think that's enough
markets to convince you of the value of
looking at a delta footprint hopefully
you'll see the value in it so thanks for
watching this video and again for the
users of my software I'm gonna be doing
that we talking about this more in the
weekly group training session so I look
forward to seeing everybody there so I
have a great have a great data have a
great day everyone bye bye